[Music]
coming up next join us for this week's
edition of book notes our guest is
george wilson chief defense
correspondent for the washington post
he discusses his book titled mud
soldiers life inside the new american
army wilson researched the book by
living with army recruits and observing
their training
[Music]
george wilson in your new book in the
introduction you open up with the first
sentence the world changed for the
united states and its army in 1966 why
did you open up that way
because i think it really did change
dramatically
1966 was the year we practically doubled
our troops on the ground and we stopped
pretending
we were there to advise the south
vietnamese army and we put enough troops
in to
do the do the operations are ourselves
so it became an american war
in 1966 because we had the troops to do
what the commanders really really wanted
to do secretly anyhow which was have
americans run their own show rather just
be sprinkled among south vietnamese
units and that changed a lot of things
the title of your new book mud soldiers
life inside the new american army is
about what
it's about today's grunt
today's soldier who
would go out on the point if we ever got
in in the next war it's the infantryman
the guy who's always cold he's always
hungry uh whether it's peace or war
and he's the first guy to get killed and
he's the first guy to fight and it's a
thin red line that defends our country
in all but a sudden nuclear holocaust so
it's the spear point of the american
army and i thought that that part of it
was important and we ought to take a
look at it how did you write it
well i wrote it by what i like to call
as a participatory journalism
i went down to fort benning and went
through basic training and advanced
advanced individual infantry training
with this
company of
troops and then when they went to fort
riley to report to their unit i went
with them there and then when they
fought the russians in california and
mock warfare
i stayed within the desert for two weeks
to see how they did how do these
apprentice infringements equip
themselves and then i looked them up
a year later and said okay you've had a
year in the army uh
what were your hopes and fears and did
the army live up to them and are you
better are you worse
how was this unique passage from a
teenager to soldier from soldier to
infantryman how did it go how did you
actually
what's what was the time frame that you
actually did this how many
months well i went down to uh
i went i went went down to
fort
benning in 1987 this summer of 87 when
the kids got off the bus with their long
hair and their gold earrings and the
drill sergeants start snapping at them
and shaping them up so it was the summer
of 87
and then the fall of 88
we went to fort riley where they
reported to their unit to be
active duty regular line infantryman
and army
gave you what kind of access complete
access
the deal was that i would only do it if
i didn't have a lieutenant lockstep in
me and uh listening in on interviews
that i could go where i please and talk
to them
when i wanted to as long as i didn't you
know interfere with their training or do
something stupid like get in their way
in the rifle range so
i have to say the army was good to its
word and they let me
be kind of the uh
invisible chronicler uh all through
their training and their duty and made
no efforts to stop me from talking to
the kids you worked full time for the
washington post as a pentagon
correspondent during that period when
you were writing this did you also do
pieces for the post yes i did
about three pieces called the new gi and
the deal with the post is that they
would let me go
off duty for them and spend full time
with this army unit
providing periodically i would give them
a look at these new soldiers and
i did so so it worked out pretty well
what have fort bennings in georgia yes
columbus georgia what happened
when you were down up close looking at
these young folks getting ready for the
army that you least expected
at least expected
the drill sergeants to welcome me i
thought you know i would be the intruder
you know as a reporter you're not
exactly welcome on military bases to
start with but with drill sergeants they
consider themselves the real
authoritarian figure and uh they they
run their own show and i thought i'd
never be able to defrost these guys that
i would always be
someone getting in their act and they
would resent it and i found just the
opposite that everybody likes to
to talk to some neutral corner and have
a listener and after i was there a
couple weeks and they saw that i wasn't
getting in the way or showboating
they started to tell me about
their problems of trying to shape up
young teenagers and being overworked and
divorces and i ended up being good
friends with a number of the drill
sergeants and that was a big surprise to
me i thought they would be the hardest
nuts to crack and they turned out to be
real regular guys did you withhold
anything that you learned from the book
on purpose because it would embarrass or
would offend yeah yes i did i i did not
use
last names of guys who tried to commit
suicide because they couldn't hack
army training i didn't see the point of
ruining their civilian careers
the incident is described in a very
level the reader and i say i'm calling
this guy so and so which is not his real
name
frankly a couple of kids who attempted
suicide wanted their names used
they wanted some some reason for uh
their sacrifice in their view but i
thought when they got a little older
they might resent that and regret it so
i i've not identified
some of the characters in here who got
in real trouble
what's your motivation for writing the
book
a i wanted to take a look at whether the
army is living up to its advertising be
all you can be
b i thought it would be really
interesting you could back down in the
mud after hearing the theoretical in
washington i kind of like to do this
periodically as you know i went on an
aircraft carrier for seven months
and i i really relate to the grunts
whether they be sailors or soldiers and
if you're away from them too long you
kind of lose touch what's real in the
military did you put fatigues on no i
didn't i debated about that the army
kind of wanted me to and i said well i'm
not going to pretend to be something i'm
not if i figure if i put fatigues on i
should do all the push-ups do everything
they did and i wasn't going to kid
myself and go through basic training
again i did that once and
i also wanted to be a neutral corner
and it turned out i think the right
decision because i wore
field khakis just regular old field
khakis and a jungle hat
and the kids when i was there felt kind
of reassured that you know they had kind
of an uncle figure that when they're off
duty they would tell me about their
homesickness and stuff they couldn't
tell their peers because everybody has
to be macho in the infantry so i was
kind of a
kind of an unexpected priest with that
portfolio out in the field with these
kids and not having a uniform enable
them to know where i was and kind of you
know i was there and i wasn't one of the
bad guys if you will kids of your own
yes i have a son who uh
could have been in the military he's at
that age and i have a daughter
did did you make such close friends of
some of these kids that you still are in
contact with them they write me
frequently and i still worry about them
and they become like second son sure
what's the
super carrier right
was that the kennedy that was the
kennedy right uss kennedy you were out
there for seven months you wrote a book
called super carrier
uh
1983 right correct
became a television show true didn't
make it as a television
what was the reason
well my theory is that supercarrier it
could have been turned into a uh a mash
kind of
uh series because there's so much human
emotion locked up in the walls of a ship
and it's a very intense experience that
cannot be duplicated on land just as the
experience of mash can't be duplicated
in a hospital you have to have it inside
that tent
but hollywood in my view decided they
were going to be hollywood and we had to
get into drugs and women and
gun play and all the things that don't
happen on a carrier so by the second
show
the the core audience that people knew
anything about the military and anything
about the navy knew this was just a sham
and tuned out
what's the or is there any major
difference between the navy the sailor
and the mud soldier
not in his human qualities or his
background but in his interest the
mud soldier
doesn't want to go to sea in most cases
and he's not as
technically oriented a sailor kind of
gets
into running an airplane running a ship
whereas a mud soldier wants to be a
rambo run up and downhill shoot guns
the midnight stalker it's a different
kind of motivation did the navy and the
army treat you differently
the army
officers were
less suspicious of me than the navy
officers on the ship
partly because i had already written
supercarrier and a number of them had
read it and figured i'd tell it like it
is but
the other thing that's probably more
important is that the army is so
appreciative
when somebody bothers to take a look at
their soldiers because it's not the most
glamorous of the services and they feel
they've been somewhat eclipsed by
the flyboys and people who have more
dramatic activities a plain old mud
soldier
is kind of an orphan so they appreciated
somebody taking the time to look at what
they were doing and i guess i'd have to
say they
they were they welcomed me a little more
one of the things i'm looking for right
now i'm sure you can remember that kind
of surprising when i read
the introduction is the number of
soldiers i thought it was much larger
than that for some reason how many
american army soldiers are there today
there's about 771 000 in the united
states army total that's half the number
that we had in vietnam at the height of
the war so we have a small army my point
is if it's going to be small it ought to
be good
and they've got the money they've got
the equipment now we've got to manage
this resource namely the soldier
and one of my regrets is we don't lean
far enough toward this new
volunteer soldier we still regard him as
a drafty
wants three hots and a cot and don't
realize you have to keep
the light at the end of his tunnel you
have to make this kid
believe that he's being all he can be if
he gets turned off and he goes right
back to some of his bad habits in
civilian life and it's a management
challenge just as teaching arithmetic's
a management challenge in a high school
if you give up on being a good teacher
in the army you could lose these kids
when i showed the audience something
you you list in the back
the graduates you have a little column
here called the graduates and we'll see
it here in just a second as soon as we
can get a close shot of this come on in
there mark let's take a look
um
who are these graduates
they are
they are the invisible patriots they're
the kids that volunteer for the infantry
even though they don't have to there's
no draft today let me interrupt because
i don't want to lose this
one of the reasons i wanted our audience
to see this is that 18 19 20 21 18 18 18
all and if you go over here on the next
page you go on for how many are listed
on this do you remember george uh there
would be about uh 120 17 18 and all that
i mean is that the average age of people
yeah they're kids
right out of high school
they usually come from a town where
it's a dead end
and going in the army is a way up
they don't want to work at mcdonald's
they want they don't want to go
to the local factory
some of them had offers of college
scholarships because of the wrestling
ability for instance but
they're sick of book work and they want
to go be a rambo
so
they joined the army infantry for
adventure and
in basic the army delivers
but in the regular units it's too boring
for them and the kids get disillusioned
how long do they sign up for
well it's two to four years
it's it's selective in the army's
in the army's interest sometimes they'll
accept two years and list these and
sometimes they won't but basically most
of these kids signed up for four years
what's their pay when they start
they get about 800
a month something like that how's that
track with what they would make if they
were outside well when you count
everything
money is not the problem they do
they do better than they do on the
civilian market for instance a couple of
these guys that i got to know well
joined the army because their wives were
pregnant and they realized they were
facing hospital bills they couldn't pay
and the army would take care of that
they didn't know whether they'd get laid
off from the job they had so the
security of the army
plus the adventure is appealing to
a good part of non-establishment in
america these are not the guys who have
the chance to go to prep school in most
cases in
college they have they have
they're working in america how many
people that apply for the army get in
well
i don't know exactly the percentages you
have to pass an entrance test
and some months you may get in with a
low score because they're accepting a
given number what they call category
fours other months they may not need
bodies to fill spaces so you have to get
a higher score to be category one or two
so it varies month by month but
a
high school average student
who is good physically could almost
guarantee getting in the army how many
of them re-up at the end of their tour
it the percentage again vary but i would
guess right now about 20 percent
is that number low or high compared to
what it used to be when we had a draft
i think it's better than during the
draft it's that's a good question
the draft
soldier didn't want to be there
and as soon as he could he got out so i
would be surprised if say in the 60s and
70s the reenlistment rate was anywhere
near as high as between 20 35 like it is
today what's known today as
some of the better duty stations for
somebody in the army
well
it used to be exciting to go overseas
and a lot of
guys joined the army thinking it's going
to be glamorous to go to germany and go
to distant places
but
now they have found out that the
economies of europe are more expensive
than around home so
germany is no longer glamorous to these
kids although very often they have no
choice so i was surprised to find out
that
when they get a little more experienced
with
what army life is like
and how expensive
germany is that they look for bases
around home so that they can continue to
be in uniform but they could get the
support structure of home like if you're
from california you might like fort ord
if you were
from the south you might rather go to
fort benning but
these soldiers are
not the from here to eternally bums with
no roots at all
they come in
wanting to better themselves
they do have alternatives
so if they can stay in the army and get
a trade and see themselves advancing
they'll work out a way to
put down roots raise family and nobody
lives in the barracks anymore for
instance
after the first
couple months of
training and you go to your regular unit
very very few live in the barracks they
get married young and then they get
apartments in town or trailers so you
don't have if your mind's eye picture of
an army is everybody living together as
single men in barracks and falling out
in formation
you're in for a surprise the barrack is
cut up into little little rooms it's
more like a college dormitory
and a fair number of soldiers
have outside activities that interest
them they don't always go down and
drink beer at the rec hall the bowling
alley
it's
somewhat
a blending of civilian and
military right right on a base
do you think
after spending all this time thinking
about the mud soldier do you think that
the mud soldier will ever be used again
in a serious way by the united states
i think yes i think we always are going
to need mud soldiers
my view is that an american rifle
company is our best high-tech weapon
because it seems to me the least likely
war is that the united states and soviet
union are going to blow each other up
with
sudden nuclear strikes that to me takes
mad men on both sides
but i can see a lot of problems in the
third world where being able to get
there with a rifle company would be
great deterrence and if need be
you might have to
take on some number of bad guys
so
who are you going to send
you're going to send either the marines
or the infantry you're not going to send
the v2 stealth bomber which costs over
half a billion each you're not going to
send missiles you're going to send these
kids
and if you look at the third world
there's lots of trouble spots
what's the difference between a
u.s marine and a u.s infantry well
if uh if you're if you're a marine
the dog-faced soldier can't do anything
if you're an infantryman while a marine
is a jar head basically
they do much the same thing the marines
have a little different uh philosophy on
their fire teams for instance
but i think american soldiers are
american soldiers whether they be
marines or infantrymen and i have no
worries about them running and letting
us down i've got some worries about
whether they're well enough lead
seems to me we've gotten into this
management syndrome where you give a guy
a rifle company for a year a year and a
half and then you put them in the staff
job and then you send them to charm
school you can't get good leading troops
and winning battles with all this
turbulence at the top
how would you change that i'd i'd do a
lot of things first thing i do i'd make
every officer who got out of west point
or rotc go through basic training with
troops we'd wear an owen cigna he'd get
no favors he would do the same thing the
kids he's going to command do that way
they would finally come to understand
that these kids have dreams
they want to be better they have
expectations they're not just automatons
out there
too many of today's officers are yuppies
they just want to run their unit and
then go on to a staff job and advance
their career to be army chief of staff i
want them to get to know their soldiers
better and the only way i know how to
make them get to know their soldiers
better is to immerse them for six weeks
with these kids so they know what
they're about then go ahead and redraw
the fire break and have the separation
from
basic training forward they couldn't
serve with the same young men that they
went through basic training with could
they they they could end up commanding
them further down the road but chances
are they would not by the time that they
were up uh senior enough to command a
company would be a new crop it'd be the
same kind of kid and they know what they
would know it made them tick but it
would not be the very guy they slept in
the barracks i mean it was just a
technical question you couldn't walk
right out of there and command that no i
don't think that's necessary or or or
desirable that's one thing i do the
other thing i'd do is i'd go back to shy
myers theory he was army chief of staff
and he said that he wanted
people to command
rifle units and battalions and companies
for three years he didn't want this in
and out stuff
and we've gotten back to the year and a
half tour the 12-month tour
and you know the new guy comes in he
takes over a rifle company he wants to
make a record for himself he wears out
the kids and the new guy comes in tries
to do the same thing the sergeants are
left there for three years or more why
not the officers
basically what do those sergeants think
of the officer
in general
they think the
officers are too much the micromanagers
and i came to agree in fact i'd bring
the polo ponies back
i think if he brought the polo ponies
back the officer would be so darn busy
getting ready for the saturday polo
match that they leave the
soldiers and sergeants alone so the
sergeants could get back to running
their units and
the
officers would do more big picture
managing instead of doing the sergeant's
work all the time you really came away
with some strong feelings
i came you know the army is a great
institution it's helping
thousands and thousands of young people
it's the best social betterment
institution we have i just want to be
all it can be and there's a lot of room
for improvement and my biggest regret is
we have this golden moment here where
you got high quality kids willing to
serve the country in peace time and
we're we're not making the most of it
we're not leaning toward this kid enough
we're not making it interesting we're
not making it fun
somehow the military's got gotten to be
workaholics
i don't see anything wrong with working
a half a day and having the kids play
baseball or basketball or do something
physical that's fun
but the new syndrome is keep them out in
the field check this block that block
and whether they're learning anything or
not keep them out in the rain i mean i
just think we ought to lighten up and
make it fun
all right the call comes from the
president he wants
ex-troops
in a hot spot in the world you hear
about it
what's your immediate reaction we we're
well served
that the kids will do great but a lot of
them will be killed because the officers
are going to have to learn their job
the officers are
poorly trained
at the academy or at
ocs
are poorly led by the top
generals i mean where's this
they're fine americans and we should be
grateful that they're willing to be
infantry officers but we don't leave
them
with rifle companies or battalions long
enough to learn their trade it's very
hard to run a battalion today you've got
to know a lot about air power
about 800
got to know a lot about air power about
artillery about movement of armored
vehicles about how to use infantry
it takes a long time to get good at that
i think it takes at least a year or more
and better three years but instead this
this guy is busy he's got paperwork he
gets command of a battalion he may go to
a few field exercises and in a year and
a half he's on a different job how old
is that
battalion commander he's probably 35 39
something like that depends on his age
could be major
usually a a battalion commander is a
lieutenant colonel
and a company commander is usually a
captain
and then a platoon leader
it's the smallest unit is a lieutenant
and i think the lieutenants and the
captains and the lieutenant colonels
ought to stay in the field longer
to get good at working with troops and a
lot of them love it and would would
rather not go to charm school and punch
their ticket they would rather stay with
the troops and those guys we want to
treasure and develop and let's stay in
their jobs
and a lot of soldiers would like to
drive a truck forever we make him become
a sergeant and a troop leader instead of
letting him drive a truck who thinks
that
first of all have you talked to the top
yes
i think i think this book is everybody
his say
i laid all these thoughts on chief of
staff of the army carl vuno
the manpower chief
he had his his say
and
max thurman
and they all were interested in my
observations they weren't you know
closed-minded about it and they said
well uh we'll think of it but you know
there are problems you have to get
officers ready to take over these bigger
jobs and you have to give them a certain
amount of staff time so i'm not saying
it's easy but i i'm saying we've lost
the sense of what's important what's
important to me is winning the next
battle if there is one and making sure
our leaders our middle management the
officers and the sergeants know
how
to win a small scrap so that these kids
don't have to be sacrificed while they
learn on the job where are you from
originally new jersey i used to play
basketball against the from here to
eternity soldiers i had four ticks and
the army was very different those days
my older sisters were not allowed to
date soldiers from fort dix it was
socially unacceptable and i'm glad
today's army has soldiers that are
considered acceptable that's how far
we've come and i just regret we're not
leaning toward this new talent enough
where did you go to college
uh i went in the navy air corps and they
sent us to georgia tech for engineering
before we went to flight training but by
the time i got the flight training they
did not need any more pilots so on my
own
i abandoned engineering which i had to
force feed myself
on to get through the navy and went to
bucknell university in louisburg
pennsylvania then what
then
i went to a series of
newspapers new jersey's biggest
newspaper at the time was the nurk
evening news
and i wanted to come to washington so i
went to congressional quarterly news
features which i found in the yellow
pages of the phone book i didn't know it
existed congressional quarterly here in
town yeah right i'd gone through all the
all the publications i knew about upap
and the papers and they had no openings
and i said did i miss anybody and
they're under new services i found
congressional quarterly so they gave me
a beachhead in washington and taught me
something about the federal government
and then i went to the washington star
what year
went to the washington star in 1960
the end of the post well no i had a i
had a delay in route as i say in the
army
i learned that you have a lot of fun on
the newspaper being utility outfield or
infield or picture catcher but you can't
make any money and by then i had a
family and
i had to get a specialty it became the
age of the specialist when i started out
the hero of the city room was the old
front page rewrite man who could make
anything sing and
after work he'd throw his teeth in his
pocket and get drunk across the street
and it was a different era
and i just got the very last of that era
and by the time i got to washington you
had to be a specialist so i
learned something about airplanes so i
went to aviation week
and space technology for five years
and at the end of that five years the
post was looking for someone to take
over
military in the space and i was a fit
and i wanted newspapers anyhow so i went
back to what year did you join the
washington post 1966. been doing what
you're doing since then right with the
periodical leaves for good behavior
to write books or whatever are you as
interested today as you were in 1966
yeah once i stopped being interested i
think i owe it to my readers and myself
to get out
i i don't want to if i lose my curiosity
then
it's time to go fishing
we're talking with george wilson and as
he periodically does he writes a book
this is his latest book you can see here
it's called mud soldiers life inside the
army the new american army
and he is also author of super carrier
which is was came out in 1986 86 and we
talked about
super carry at that time and now we're
talking about the mud soldier in the
army
770 some thousand
right in your army soldiers how many in
the navy
about 600 a little over 600
marine corps
marine corps is about roughly 200 000
and finally the air force it's about 660
something like that
total numbers
1.2 million men under arms on active
duty
what do you think that'll be 10 years
from now
uh with gorbachev's
direction
and borrowing
emergency did you mean 1.2 or 2.2
no uh 2.1 is what i meant i'm sorry you
said 1.2 yeah i reversed it 2.1 million
under arms
i i think the army is going to suffer a
cut or enjoy a cut however you look at
it
of
at least 100 000
in
the next eight years
at least
given the way that soviet threat is
diminishing
and all bets are off if that changes
i think the air force will go down
at least
40 000
and if we don't do something about the
prices of weapons we're going to have to
cut more and more manpower because
it's very tempting for a politician
who's trying to get the spending down to
reduce his payroll because if i fire you
today i don't have to pay you next week
if i cancel a weapon i don't realize
those savings for five years or so
and if we let ourselves
buy too many of these stealth bombers
and stealth fighters
we're going to price ourselves out of
manpower and
i think there's a balance here that we
have to worry about
you really want
to spend up to a billion dollars on one
airplane and have the air force take
turns flying it because there's no money
for anything else
we're getting into this
structural disarmament syndrome where
we disarm ourselves by making the
weapons so expensive
and some of these cuts are driven by
international events but some of it very
frankly are driven by
trying to save money and it's it's easy
to cut manpower and
congress is doing that pentagon's doing
that
so
it's time for a good look at
our priorities
dick cheney
he's off to a good start
i think he made a mistake by
lambasting the chief of staff the air
force and public
for going up to the hill and trying to
find the middle ground on
two missiles the mx and the [ __ ] man
which are the residuals on that yes yes
the residuals the
professional military represented that
you know it's praise and public
and rebuked and private
and cheney broke that
rule in his first few weeks in office
i know why he might have done it i want
to make a point that i'm in charge now
and nobody's going to go up there
freelancing
and
speaking without
coming checking with me first i mean i
can see a
manager an executive trying to take hold
the military
but
especially since cheney never served in
the military himself i think it was a
little bit insensitive to start off that
way by balling out a four-star general
what what are the residuals
residuals are the
professional military is more skeptical
of this guy than they would have been
otherwise i think he can win back their
confidence but
uh i think that that was a bad way to
start on the personnel side of this this
mafia that it's it's in the pentagon i
mean they can they can undo you whether
you know it or not whether you think
you've got an order issued but whether
it's carried out or not it's something
else again so you need the confidence of
your
of your military even though they will
salute obey
you have to establish a rapport there
and i think he will but i think that was
a bad way to start on the budget i think
he
has got high marks he actually cut
something he actually canceled something
and it's very interesting that
congress 22 yeah the v22 the f-14d the
lhx helicopter
is that you know when you it's hard when
you're a civilian you're reading
these articles to know what really
matters from your perspective was did
the marine corps need the osprey
it's a nice to have explain what it is
well okay the osprey is a advanced
aircraft
where it can take off like a helicopter
because you just
tilt the propellers of the plane
downward and it pushes the plane in the
air and then when you get airborne you
can move the propellers up to the wings
like a regular aircraft and then it goes
forward so it's a beautiful sounding
combination of taking off like a
helicopter and flying like a real
airplane has great potential for
civilian markets i mean you wouldn't
have to have great big runways in your
local airport
but
it it it it's taking the marines to the
poor house in the cadillac
it's going to be a heavy cost of that
bird and
i think cheyney said it's a great
airplane and it'd be nice to have but
congress has said zero growth in the
budget and something's got to give and
we have helicopters that are new like
the army's blackhawk so we'll let the
marines go from the ship to shore on
existing helicopters rather than buy
this osprey which was faster and flew
higher and so forth and the marines said
they needed that to dodge the modern air
defenses to get the marines from ship to
shore so it's a legitimate argument but
and it's a tough decision it's probably
the only it's probably the reason no
secretary of defenses had nerve to make
the decision because it is a close call
and you have a marine lobby that's real
but cheney decided that we couldn't
afford it and he had the guts to make it
and similarly with the f-14d
you know grumman desperately is lobbying
to get that fighter plane
in production
and he said we just can't have
everything and he cut that
and he told the army that
we know your helicopters are wearing out
but not now we don't have money to get
into the lhx in a big big way and apache
is going to have this which is the fire
fire attack helicopter apache is going
to have to end earlier than you hadn't
planned so he made a lot of
cancellations rather than the usual
stretch out and putting the problem off
to the next guy so i think that
he's off to a promising start that way
but it's just beginning i mean the match
the mismatch between the money in sight
and the pentagon's five-year plan is
about 150 billion dollars off so we've
got a lot of cutting to do a lot of
blood in the floor a lot of lobbying
ahead 92 is going to be a horrendous
year john tower told me before he got
rejected as
defense secretary he figured he could
finesse 1990
he could fit in s 1991 but 92-93
you're going to really see a
restructuring of the defense
establishment of this country what do
you think would have been the difference
between a john tower defense department
and a dick cheney defensively
not not an awful lot
uh i think tower would have made
similarly tough decisions
i think he might even cut deeper
tower
is a real tough guy and i think he was
well suited for the job at hand which is
to restructure the pentagon by
subtraction
after all these years of addition it's
much easier to restructure by adding on
adding on everybody's happy when you
start to restructure by addition
everybody's unhappy and he's mean enough
and he knows where the bodies are buried
no
general would roll him he knows what
senators where where they're coming from
so i think he would have been a good
secretary of defense but i don't think
he would start out much differently than
cheney has
we're talking about the military and the
pentagon and we're also talking about
george wilson's new book which is called
mud soldiers life inside the new
american army
published by scribners right why'd you
choose this publisher well they put out
super carrier and
they had a lot of success with that and
they wanted me to do another book so it
just seemed to be a natural to try it
again how do you write
painfully
really
well it's always painful because
you know anybody who finishes a book has
a salute for me whether they sell it or
not because
when you don't have to go down the
basement and and write every morning
when you could you know read the paper
or take the dog for a walk or do
something fun it takes a lot of
willpower to go ahead and do it on your
own time but the way i write is i'm
i'm only creative
in the morning if if i try and write all
day i have to rewrite it the next day i
find that i'm good from about
five in the morning till noon time and
then i can
i can do dunky work like make phone
calls and
do some proofreading or reading but as
far as writing a narrative and telling a
story and
making it adventuresome for the reader i
find i have to be up on my game and i'm
not i'm not very good at night or
at the end of the day and
i found it very hard to to write after
work for instance which some guys do how
long did you take to physically write
the book
i guess i'd have to say
about six months of the two years i
spent on it
and how what physically how do you do
you write it on a computer or take part
yeah i'm afraid i've
been hauled dragging screaming into the
computer age
i have a word processor and
i don't pretend to know all what's
inside it i kind of regard it as a
garden hoe i wanted to take out the
weeds and i don't want to know all the
technology whereas my son is just the
opposite he knows everything about
computers and all i want to do is use it
like a
advanced typewriter which i do
you send the
product off to the publisher immediately
or your editor or do you re-edit
yourself no
to my surprise i found out that the
publishers at least my publisher and i
think it's true of a number of others
don't want to have to read a manuscript
twice
so they'd rather get the whole thing if
they have confidence you're going to
deliver on it rather than read a part of
it and have to remember what they had
read before and then go back in so i i
put it in one
one final graph that's what they get
here's uh who you dedicated this book to
it's really easy to understand to
american mud soldiers everywhere who
gives so much and asks so little
let's take a look here at some of the
pictures um and talk about these people
christian tweety sylvester before
and right next to him is a picture of
him
afterward and what what are the two
pictures
this is uh tweety in his uh hometown of
lincoln california
and uh he had a terribly unhappy boyhood
he and his stepfather didn't get along
he couldn't seem to discipline himself
in high school
he got into drugs he couldn't
keep up his grades he missed school he
he just didn't fit and thought that
maybe he ought to kill himself and then
he thought maybe there's something for
me after all so he tried the army
brian trotter before
and brian trotter afterwards he's one of
the army's success stories
he he was in all kinds of trouble in his
home state of virginia his parents and
he were at dagger points
and his parents have said the army saved
brian and brian says the army saved me
and
says if my country goes to war i want to
be out front
let's see here we have another one a
gentleman that looks like he's losing a
little bit of his hair where's this
yeah he's ray mcdaniel as he entered
with hair down on his shoulders at fort
benning and they said okay son you're in
the army you're in basic training and
here's your barber there's only one kind
of haircut so he's
he's losing his locks there much to his
regret
how'd you pick the people you picked to
feature
just uh kind of immerse myself in the
training company and pick what i thought
would be a representative number of
interesting characters
and also ones with tipify i had some
blacks and some whites
we've got some more
pictures here
here's a drill sergeant randy stover
tell us about him well randy stover is
that here was the hero of everybody in
basic training
i have to remember that
vietnam to these kids who were 17 and 18
was like world war one to you and me
and the war they related to believe it
or not was grenada
randy stover was a rifleman in grenada
he was a terrific drill sergeant because
he did everything they did and he could
do it all well
and he was a coach he's the kind of
coach you want your son to be under and
he was the hero of
the kids in delta company at fort
benning
let's see what else we've got here pick
one of those pictures mark and let's see
oh there's a good one right there no no
down here the one over here right here
i'm sorry the audience can't see what
we're doing here we'll
i don't want that one i want to appear
the one up above it
no no
well right there
please thank you
okay that's
that's that's that's that's the drill
sergeant that they nicknamed z monster
his name was mario zuniga
and this is what they call shock
treatment it's the first hour in the
united states army where they report to
the training company
and a lot of kids have been in this
reception station which is like a
holding pen
until they get assigned their units and
life is very easy and slack in this
reception center and they get the wrong
idea so the drill sergeants thought it
was incumbent upon them to let them know
that they were in the army and by god
the drill sergeant's word was law so
that's old z monster shouting at some
recruit that he can't hear him he can't
hear him speak louder speak louder
what's the purpose of that
just to assert their authority as one
drill sergeant said you know i'm five
foot two i weigh 130 pounds and i've got
i've got a boss around these uh
200 pound former football players and
some of them have
been in ghetto gangs and i have to
assert my authority from day one from
hour one
to let them know that while they're
under my command i am the law
now there's some debate as to whether
shock treatment is necessary and some
units are doing away from it but the
feeling of the drill sergeants is they
have to give them a cold shower and get
their attention
have they as the army studied
the method of training
uh
where it isn't deeply but in great depth
i guess the same thing to the point
where they're absolutely sure that
they're doing it the right way no
there's they're always tinkering with it
and my biggest criticism of their
training is
that they overload the drill sergeant to
the point that no man should have to
take that much load of working you know
14 16 hours a day six days a week i
don't think you can maintain your
patience with that heavier workload i
think we ought to put put a uh a little
more
uh help in there with a drill sergeant
either more drill sergeants or perhaps
put in a
first lieutenant with some combat
experience that would be my first
recommendation to help them
uh run these training companies although
the drill sergeants would resent that
the other thing is i think it's time for
a look at how long it takes to learn
something
these uh
this manual is you know it takes so many
hours to learn how to plant a claymore
mine in the ground or throw a grenade i
think these kids are so smart that we
ought to go right into
more of this fun action more of this
rambo stuff where you
teach them how to go through the woods
and take out a sniper and i just love
that and it's terrific training
and make make it more fun by putting
some grenade ranges out in the back of
the barracks and have contests and use
the plastic replicas of any any tank
weapons
rethink the whole
regime of we got bright kids they want
to learn let's give it to them instead
of just making them stand out there in a
grand stand or sit down the grandstand
hour after hour here some guy drone away
at you know how to how to work the
claiborne claymore mine or you know how
to take apart your weapon it's too
boring right now they ought to make it
more interesting can't you just hear
though a
viewer in the audience who is a
veteran of the service saying he's got
to be crazy make it more fun this is
serious business well uh
you join the inventory and you want to
be a rambo you're doing it for
excitement
and
part of
part of excitement it's it's fun to be
in a mock combat situation with your
buddies if you're the sniper and i'm the
guy
coming through the woods trying to wipe
you out that that's a game and maybe it
sounds immature but
combat
is
you do in combat what you learn in
training and i would like to see us have
more of this
in the field in the woods actual
exercises so the kids get really
confident know how to communicate with
each other
rather than
so much of the sitting in the grandstand
and listening
you opened this book up uh
i think it was the big red one the
battle right 1866 66 right why
well i was at fort riley
and i read the citation
of this sergeant robinson james robinson
and he won the medal of honor for his
activity in this battle i had never
heard about even though i've been a
combat reporter in vietnam twice 66 and
72. and i said
that must have been some battle
and better than that
this
robinson was a member of the same
charlie company i was following through
so i thought
why not make the connection between this
is what these kids on with would have to
do in combat
and this is what they're like today
so the way to
do that for the book purposes was to
look up the survivors of this ferocious
battle the charlie company fought in 66
where they were surrounded
by a whole vietcon
battalion
and
describe what really happens in actual
combat and then ask the question to the
reader who would volunteer to go out
there and get shot at like that and
experience that horror how many people
were killed in this battle in 66 there
was about there was eighty percent
casualty of uh
wounded and killed i think it was 34
killed out of a company of 134.
heavy
heavy heavy amount of machine guns were
fired in on their narrowing perimeter
okay we've got some other picture we'll
get it to in just a second but what
happened to the people have you talked
to any of the people in the in the
vietnam
in that battle in vietnam right this is
johnny libs who i
looked up he was he he led the battle
because the company commander was
wounded early on and he was the hero of
the battle in the sense that
he saved
what he could of the company by calling
an artillery so close to the perimeter
that the vietcong every time they masked
for the final assault
were broken up by the artillery that
johnny kept calling in and he and his
few survivors were all in this very
tight circle firing outward and they're
up against about eight machine guns all
slicing up their company they're up
against snipers in the trees that were
shooting people in the back as they were
laying in the ground it was just a
nightmare of an operation
where is he today
johnny lives is in evansville
indiana and he runs a
candy company there
and he and his
fellow survivors
have said that
talking out this battle for the purposes
of the book
have made them well again because they
could finally get over their guilt now
that they have it in perspective here's
a congressional medal of honor that's
jimmy robinson he's the one who inspired
me to reconstruct the battle by going
from his role up to
everyone else i could find still why
no he he died charging a 50 caliber
machine gun nest almost cut him in half
and how do you find out what his story
is today where did you go well i went to
the army history sources i talked to his
family to find out what kind of a boy he
was and
there was
quite a lot of official records on that
battle in his role when the young fellas
come in today into charlie company do
they know the history
is the history on the wall somewhere in
the barracks well the that picture in
the citation is on the
on the wall but
again i think we could do a little
better by
uh instilling these kids with a sense of
their regiment and the company and the
tradition and we do some of that in the
army today but i think we should do more
who's this
that's phil hall he was the machine
gunner in the battle and he was very
anxious to have the story of their
heroism told and he never could
get anybody interested in the army to
reconstruct what had happened and
he's been very generous to me because i
took an interest in his role in
everybody else's and
he's visiting the vietnam memorial there
in washington
looking up the names of the guys who did
not survive that very same battle are
you surprised when you go down to that
memorial almost any day and see as many
people as you do
yes i'm surprised and i'm
i'm always emotionally
struck
with almost a knockout punch when i read
some of the
messages that they leave at the wall
it's almost like the wall in jerusalem
where you see
uh
jewish
people
saying their prayers and leaving a
message in the cracks of the wall this
this vietnam wall has become to
one generation anyhow like the great
wall in jerusalem is to religious jews
here's tweety again with his mother this
time how important is the family
relationships for these young soldiers
well there's usually somebody
who keeps keeps these kids who
haven't found their way uh in
society afloat and in this case tweedy's
mother was
his heroine and she kept encouraging him
and then he missed her so much when he
went in the army but of course he
couldn't admit it so this is the first
time that he reunions were there at the
end of basic training
and usually there's some member of the
family not always the parents who
inspire these kids to the point they at
least try and make something themselves
by joining the army
who's this gentleman
that's captain jim fleener he's a
kentuckian and proud of it and he's my
idea of a good officer he's a teacher
he's a human being
the men just
worshiped him as a role model
and
most of all he he cared about his men
and they could tell once the once the
troops sense that you care about them
they'll do anything for you they'll walk
through fire and somehow he projected
that
and it was a very happy company at fort
benning how do you convince someone in
the military that you care about them
especially in the middle of
basic training
i think it's hard to fake
either you do or you don't and and if
you don't really care about these kids
you're just doing it to advance your
career
they have the
the best manure separator in the world
they sense this immediately and the word
goes that this guy doesn't care about us
i think most officers do care but they
have to express it a little more readily
and dramatically by asking about
the kids and once in a while having a
barbecue for the families of the company
to make it more of an army family
theoretically the army is all for that
unfortunately the training schedule and
filling all the blocks gets in the way
and
very often it doesn't get done for
instance a young wife at fort riley had
never met the company commander
that uh her husband had served on her
for almost a year
well that's not the way it's supposed to
work you're supposed to have some sense
of identity with your army if you're a
young army wife
volunteer army
we're going to have it for a while we
ever go back to the draft
we'll have to go back to the draft if we
ever get in a major war because we're
kidding ourselves that
an army of seven hundred thousand plus
is enough to fight anywheres so these
these kids are going to hold the line
until the draft can produce the
replacements
we'll go back to the draft
only i think if we have a national
emergency i think the volunteer army is
here to stay in one form or the other
we're just going to look at a series of
pictures you have here about our new
soldiers anybody on here that you
particularly remember more than others
well they're all kind of interesting uh
here here this this right here on
this fella all right that's glenn dao
he's in maine
from maine he uh
got bored being a carpenter he thought
he could be more by joining the army and
he did so
uh he resented the amount of
time they wasted when he was at
fort riley he he wanted to be more than
he could be and they didn't lean his way
enough and this fellow that's spank
barker he joined the army because he was
working in a restaurant in california he
was bored he saw no future he had a wife
he thought that he could make something
of himself as he told me i wanted to be
something more than a little fat kid
came in the army
overweight
kind of self-conscious about himself he
gained a lot of traction and he just
finished re-enlisting
going down the page mark let's see who
else
right below mr barker who's that
gentleman aaron henson aaron henson he's
from texas
he had a a daughter he had
tried to be a fireman in his hometown of
texas and the white establishment made
excuses of why he couldn't join the fire
department even after he had passed the
test
he got kind of embittered because he
didn't really get smacked in the face
with prejudice until he became 18.
then he decided that the army offered a
chance for him to discipline himself and
to make something himself and make his
daughter proud of him
and he had a very rough beginning
he tried to kill himself at one point
because he just couldn't adjust the army
life but then he became
an outstanding soldier and is doing well
in germany at this moment kevin britton
kevin brewton same kind of story he was
getting nowheres in alabama
he uh thought that he was falling into
bad habits and maybe the army would
straighten him out and make a man of him
and as far as i can tell he's doing well
right below him
patrick i can't see yeah he's doing well
dickerson yeah yeah he he joined the
army uh because for the adventure he
wanna have some fun
and uh he he took the army life and as
far as i know he's still doing well he
did not go on to riley with me he went
somewhere else
eric uh is it harbor right i can't say
yeah they're hard yeah he's a mud
soldier who thought that the army
offered better prospects than he could
find around home and last i talked to
him
he was glad that he had done it
it disciplined himself but but here
again he's wondering whether
they're teaching him something he can
use once he gets out of the army is
there uh and you've been around the
pentagon for a lot of years
too many probably is there a favorite
service inside the pentagon that you
know
i don't know how to ask that but i mean
is there a service that people would
defer to over the others in the in
they'd rather have the navy involved in
a conflict with the marines
than they would the army of the air
force is there any kind of favoritism
that you see from the top down
well i'm more worried about just the
opposite it seems like we can't do
anything anymore without making
all four services have a role in for
instance there was no reason
that you couldn't have had just the navy
and the marines do grenada
there was no reason in my view to have
f-111s join the navy planes to bomb
libya but we've gotten the syndrome now
where it's got to be a forest service
show so the air force has to have a
piece of the action take the
highly secret
attempt to rescue the hostages from iran
in 1980 we had to have marine pilots go
from the navy aircraft carrier we had to
have
the air force involved in the c-130 and
the refueling and we had to have
uh the army uh as part of the troops
so it's just the opposite we've got this
jointness
syndrome where a military man is
supposed to learn something about all
the services which is okay but then when
we go on a combat operation we seem
compelled to give every service a piece
of the action i think we ought to get
away from that
the book is called mud soldiers life
inside the new american army our author
is george c wilson who is a military
correspondent for the washington post
thank you very much
[Music]
that concludes this interview with
author george wilson you can see book
notes again later this evening at about
11 20 eastern time
stay with us now for capital agenda
[Music]
join c-span for special programming
commemorating man's first steps on the
moon